hi everyone i'm the co-founder and ceo
at talking face
and i wanted to record a new video
uh to showcase uh features that has
turned very
popular for a lot of different companies
automatic
text classification so if you go to a
gameface.co
and then you look for zero shot
classification here we're going to use a
model
that has been shared by the facebook
research
team which allows you to do any sort of
text classification and thanks to our
inference api to
integrate it into your product or
workflow in just a matter of minutes
uh just a few lines of code really
as an input you feed it
any sort of text it can be a customer
email
a product description a news article
product review
a comment an invoice that you transcribe
with a cr
any sort of text you are dealing with
really
then you define class names which are
going to be your classification labels
again it can be any sort of
uh classes that you're dealing with
even if they're very specific to your
industry
to your use case or to your domain and
what the model
is going to do is uh predict
and give you a score of what are
the most probable classes so here it's
predicting
obviously that it's about mobile
what's super powerful is that you don't
need to do any training
you don't need to know pythwatch or
tensorflow or
to know any machine learning really to
use the state-of-the-art model
here you can see how you can use it
with our inference api
so that we run these predictions for you
with the lowest latency and cost
possible
let me maybe show you a different
example
for example if you have a legal document
this document
refers to the creation
of the company hugging face
right um and let's have the classes
incorporation from raising illegal
he had multiple classes and it detected
correctly that
it's about incorporation even if the
word wasn't there
it relies on deep understanding and not
keyword and exact match
and that it was kind of like a illegal
text
whatever the classification you can
think of now you can really integrate it
into your product or workflow in a
matter of minutes
and it's uh really affordable
too for example you can start using this
for up to 10 million characters which
gives you a lot to play with
with our 199 per month subscription
we even have a seven days free trial
that you can start on
hugging face dot co slash pricing and if
you're interested i'd be
happy to jump on a call to run you
through how it works
so just comment on this video reply
that you're interested on the bottom and
mention the people who you think could
be interested
and i reach out thank you very much